ed miliband's here nice to see you good
to be with you coming in uh early for us
this morning a lot to talk about let's
pick up on um what mr diadem was talking
there about and uh the sausage wars
whether or not they're going to be fixed
today it does look as though
the eu has made some concessions we'll
hear more about them later on gone 50
percent of the way
might not be enough
i mean i hope there's compromise on both
sides
i think people will be scratching their
heads because this was an agreement
signed a couple of years ago by boris
johnson he said it was a fantastic
triumph it was all going to be fine and
now they want to rip up their own
protocol there must be a way through
this
compromise on both sides make this work
that's got to be the answer i actually
think there's a case for a wider eu uk
veterinary agreement because that would
then make the good situation in northern
ireland much easier it would agree
common standards we've been calling for
that for some months but there must be a
way through this
does the government not have a point
though in that uh the eu wants the
european court to oversee it that's like
the mark in their own homework
i think what's happening here is that
the
both sides are arguing about the thing
they signed but but you know and and
david frost was saying yesterday
uh that that they wish they hadn't
signed it or that it was it was all done
in a rush but you know boris johnson
told us that this was the right
agreement that this would be very good
for northern ireland i do think you've
got a responsibility when you sign up
for something
to make sure that it's the right thing
for the whole of the united kingdom and
and they obviously didn't do that so
when they say it was oven ready you
don't think it won't well no it was
half-baked obviously
i like what you did there um talk to me
about what's going on um with this um
climate report and what the environment
agency is is saying you've referred
to a green wash as opposed to a
whitewash ahead of the climate well
there's this very important summit k in
in november i mean just about to start a
couple of weeks time uh where the whole
world is coming together to try and
agree climate targets for the future and
people were saying well don't these
summits happen all the time aren't they
just sort of a whole talking shop
actually these things are supposed to be
real and and this was envisaged six
years ago when there was the paris
summit of 2015 some people remember that
was a successful summit that said the
world needs to keep a carbon emissions
they keep global warming to 1.5 degrees
now
that i'm gonna be a bit nerdy here maybe
you'd expect me to be uh there's some
maths here why don't you eat a bacon
butter i would i would okay fine you're
you're on that's a deal so so we know
what the numbers tell us which is that
the world was due to be emitting 53
billion tons of carbon emissions in 2030
to keep global warming to 1.5 degrees we
need to reduce that by 28 billion tons
to 25 billion tons so it's a 28 billion
ton gap and so far the pledges made for
glasgow are only four billion tons so
it's four versus 28 we're a long way
from where we need to be
and i sort of think the prime minister
does need to get a grip on this we're
the hosts of this summit you know we
need to be putting pressure on our
dashboard that we put up every day i'm
sure you might have seen it before it
sort of
illustrates yeah co2 emissions and also
the third line down talks about the time
left yeah to uh stop the temperatures
getting to one and a half degrees
celsius well exactly and that that
expresses it very very well and um
and so
and you know
we need to be putting pressure on all
the major countries including countries
like australia where we're doing a trade
deal with them and we're saying to them
you can drop your temperature
commitments we shouldn't be doing that
we should be putting pressure on them we
should be working with the really
vulnerable countries the countries that
fear be you know complete destruction uh
when global warming goes one above one
and a half degrees to put pressure on
countries like china that's really
important and we should be certainly
setting an example at home
i think
there's a theme with this government i
don't think they've treated this summit
with the seriousness it deserves alex
sharma who's the president has actually
done a good job but the rest of
government has sort of walked on by on
the other side and i think that's a
problem so has the prime minister not
been paying a big enough role no he
hasn't and you know is that why other
countries are not taking much notice i
think the chinese don't seem to be i
think that is part of the problem look
look you know we're we're two and a half
weeks from this summit
um
you know i'm trying to imagine gordon
brown for example before the financial
when he was hosting the summit the
financial crisis would he have been
touring the beaches of europe two and a
half weeks before that summit no he'd
been touring the world trying to get
trying to get the best outcome twisting
arms cajoling people pushing people
pushing our friends the americans
pushing others you know to go further
faster that's what the prime minister
needs to be doing this really matters
this is you know this is like when world
leaders get put on the spot that's what
that's that's the purpose of this summit
it's like the embarrassment factor what
are you doing are you doing your bit but
as the host that's what we need to be
doing and we're not doing it but you
can't accuse us of being bystanders and
then look at the likes of china who you
know unless they also decide to pick up
the manchester totally then totally they
need to step up but you know the reason
why the paris summit 2015 worked is that
there was an alliance of countries like
ours and the developing and vulnerable
countries to put pressure on countries
like china the problem is that the
developing and vulnerable countries are
facing such challenges we haven't
delivered on the finance we promised
them uh we haven't vaccinated the world
as boris johnson promised at the g7 so
they're pointing the finger out it's his
fault it isn't just his fault but there
hasn't been a proper strategy for this
summit this it's what's called the high
ambition coalition of the developing and
vulnerable countries and the developed
countries that hasn't properly locked
into gear we need to do that quickly
before this summit happens
i suppose the specter at the feast some
might say
would always be the potential of uh
trump winning the next u.s election
because we know what happened with the
paris agreement when he took charge it's
a big massive problem i mean that that
threat is a massive problem to be fair
to joe biden he is trying to step up on
this he's trying to step up at home he's
trying to step up internationally but
you're completely right that you know
that's why we've got a window
you know this glasgow summit is a window
and the eyes of the world are going to
be on us we've got to take it more
seriously you know boris johnson that
would be a success
getting as far as we can to this 28
billion ton gap and not being at four
you know that is way short of where we
need to be we don't necessarily need to
get there all the way in one go because
we might have another bite at the cherry
but in a couple of years time but but
we've got to get further than we are
you've got you're going to re this is
that intensity i was at the copenhagen
summit in 2009 with gordon brown he
wasn't even the host actually gordon
brown and he he played a key role in
that so so we've really got to really
push you know you've got to slightly
put the pressure on the world leaders
the other world leaders how do we do
that well you can do that you can do
that because you see no one my lesson
from copenhagen which didn't go that
well is that nobody really wants to be
the villain of the piece
but at the moment
some of the developing countries
thinking we're the villain of the piece
we the developed world because we're not
delivering on the finance that we
promised them as i said we haven't
delivered on vaccinations so so let's
deliver for them let's have a proper
alliance with them and then let's put
pressure on the likes of china to
actually step up talk to me about the
pandemic and the damning report that
came out yesterday labour not without
guilt you didn't hold the government's
feet to the flames to try and bring down
lockdown a week earlier that could
potentially save 20 000 lives is what
the report is saying i put to one of
your colleagues yesterday would he like
to
say sorry to the 20 000 families who
needlessly lost loved ones he didn't
want to say sorry well i think
collectively we should apologize look i
think collectively the whole of politics
should apologize i think just to pick
you up on one thing i was reading
yesterday jonathan ashford two weeks
before lockdown happened was saying
hang on a minute isn't the a lot of the
advice that we should be moving further
and faster with these intervention
measures that measures so he he did
raise it but of course look government
as a whole politics as a whole let down
uh the the the families um the people
who died app absolutely now the
government is in the lead on that they
need to be held to account for that i'm
glad that oliver dowden has apologized
on your program uh to the families
because you know i think it's
you know we've got to learn lessons from
this we've got to learn lessons from
this about what went wrong i also think
there are deeper lessons about some of
the inequalities of our country the
deprivation there is in our country
which i think is part of this that's one
of the reasons we've been affected badly
but of course you know i'm afraid the
way the government handled this was
chaotic and and
and they were deeply unprepared
um how prepared do you think we are down
at felix stowe 36 percent of containers
i think come in through felixstowe um
oliver dowden said the situation was
getting better this morning but a lot of
christmas toys will come in through
there i mean grinch stealing christmas
is i'm sure what we'll see is some of
the headlines in the baby look the whole
supply chain crisis and the hgv
situation is is terrible we've known
this problem the government's known this
problem was coming for years the
problems in the industry
they haven't planned earlier on in the
in the in the summer i was warning about
this problem and they were saying no
it's scaremongering it's scaremongering
from the industry it wasn't scare
mongering it was they were telling the
truth they were saying there's a real
problem here short term you are going to
have to have more foreign drivers come
in medium long term you've got to solve
the skills problems in this industry
you've got to get the people into this
industry help people with the training
some of the costs of training are big
there's clearly a lot that needs to be
done here yeah certainly don't want your
leader to be a lorry driver did you see
what you did yesterday
come on it's not it's hardly the bacon
sandwich is okay i mean
he certainly he would have failed
apparently his test so he was he was
drawing attention to the fact that we
need trained hgv drivers that was it was
all part of the plan yeah you decided
what you want for christmas yet i've got
a cable breakfast mug if you want one
you're on excellent